[Music]
in trust no one news submitted by not so
gentrified now we're a fake FedEx worker
tied up a family while his partner stole
cash and jewelry from their home so this
is really that's cash we've got footage
of this but I got to tell you guys the
opener on this thing because this [ __ ]
is so stupid and oh no no if y'all think
you would be this dumb probably I'm
pretty dumb this on which side of the
family is dumb yeah so the family the
family opens up the door and this is in
Brooklyn and Brooklyn well the house in
Brooklyn so they must be doing some
right and they got a lot of money but
yeah so the FedEx worker shows up and
has a package here's the thing yeah let
me sign it and then leave right but the
facts oh the Frederick's person there
were two of them one was not dressed as
a FedEx worker and then the other well
they don't say maybe not but the second
guy was standing behind him and then the
first guy pulls out an NYPD badge and
says like hey I'm with the police
we need to search your home why would it
draw your warrant why would our officer
be dressed as a FedEx worker but but if
you're not knowledgeable and I can I
think any 50 year old mom like a regular
mom would even me I consider it if they
show me a badge uh actually I'd start
shooting I may be dumb so a guy calls me
last week I don't know how much I'm
allowed to talk about this cuz it's like
real yeah yeah do it no no they were
like legal real did you sign in da no
but so one of my friends has make up
fake names yeah so one of my friends is
getting a really big government job
really big it puts me as a reference
okay so I get a call at nine o'clock
from like a random number didn't answer
and I get the voicemail says hey this is
so-and-so from the FBI Wow and I was
like oh you're like all my friends prank
give me let me call him back no and I
remember my friend told me that I was on
this reference list so I expected it I
expected this like six months ago so I
called him back and it's actually kind
of scary he's like yeah this is whatever
Johnny who with the FBI I'm in front of
your house my house he's like yeah
yeah of course I'm home it's 2:00 a.m.
[ __ ] no it was it was like it
was like 9:00 in the morning it's like
9:00 in the morning when the blinds and
look no but so I did and think about how
dumb you guys think this person is I
might be dumb too it just was like a
random dude in a suit like a 55 year old
dude I was like yeah man come on in the
house conversation yeah yeah so he had
to interview me for the reference and so
he came I just I was like yeah man you
want some water or something I'm nervous
because I don't like like I'm not
familiar with the FBI or even just
police probably didn't show up in a suit
and he goes hey I'm FBI just kidding on
the jack I'm the FedEx it that is true
and then he sat down but then he sat
down he's like well I have to do this
legally and he shows me his fetid FBI
badge but I don't know what to look for
like you should actually take it from
him and do what they do at the club
metal and it looked like it looked like
out of a movie but what are the
reference do I have I've never dealt
with the FBI and then he asked me a
series of questions you super nice yeah
because it's like a big deal search time
just to pound out are you [ __ ] wired
are you people about this oh yeah I
don't think he would've I don't know so
then yeah they ask you questions like
how long have you known this person is
one of the last time you contacted them
do they have any substance or alcohol
issues that you would be aware of then
it starts to get weird though I like to
do you think they would have any
international influence by any reason
loominatee help you so funny if you're
like well I know they hung out with like
an Egyptian god named Isis or something
yeah and they were there out in Syria
on a vacation that's it that's all I
know I feel like if you're not guilty or
nothing you know if you're drug dealer
you're gonna ask the cop for a warrant
because you don't want him to come here
but if your dog guilts you anything you
see a badge I'd be like all right no I
wouldn't let any cop in well now after
this story I'm gonna think about it but
otherwise I just let him in if they had
a Fed Ex outfit and they had a badge I'm
starting to shoot the FedEx the FedEx
outfit does make a little different than
my story yeah I'm not letting cops in
unless I called them like if some should
happen and then they came and it's cuz I
called you think I'm done though yeah
you gotta throw the [ __ ] knife at
what they called you it's true and I
knew it was coming but that's the thing
like your friend warned you that they
she did they didn't like I would have
said hey email we might be coming by
tomorrow are you available I don't know
if they're allowed to do that seems like
I'm at the front door maybe they have to
so you don't like coordinate stuff now
Monty I think I think that's why so she
can't tell me like all right so yeah so
there's actually security footage of
this so it's a wealthy family they and
like I don't know if they were scouting
these people if they knew what they did
or what personally scouted them well
yeah prom I guess like but it kind of
just made it seem I give a surprise
there was so the first they still show
the badge and the family's like oh yeah
I like come in I would have stuck a
knife in there girl
no you're not [ __ ] coming into this
house you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] yeah so
the for the second guy immediately goes
upstairs and start searching the house
and found a safe upstairs and so that's
when they tied the family up that's when
they tied them up saves concussion and
they actually everyone a lot of people
old people maybe a lot of people FC yeah
because I dress the government this this
is a news thing but you're not gonna
tell the damn story they can't be the
news can't be taken about security
deposit boxes yes well you know cash in
there it will be broke off as an old
white guy no you put cash in your bank
was an old white kids bar go back there
that's been like actually like tying up
the family
and they're like the whole we got like
dude the cops are watching Star Trek
Star Trek that sucks
that's scary yeah so big FedEx worker
ties up Brooklyn family while partner
steals a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars in cash and discard that they
had to scout that no way it's randomly a
hundred I don't know much about New York
but I thought Brooklyn was like biggie
and like nice oh it's all pretty nice
it's not it's not a black neighborhood
notes
it got gentrified like Harlem no their
Bronx Bronx is live yeah well I thought
well biggie was like we're Brooklyn yeah
like in the 80s 70s he's not from okay
well I don't know I'm not an proclaim
there's like mostly Italians none no I
think he was from Brooklyn but I think
now it's like nice because it's really
close it's right across the bridge from
Manhattan so like the world kind of
maybe that's why he had such mass appeal
because like it wasn't just like you
didn't just appeal to black people or
like people were like no Brooklyn maybe
I think it was I think it was more broke
than though I'm right here as well
where's Brooke there's a song where he
starts off saying that so and it is a
freestyle that he did we got to think
that's 30 years ago more oh yeah yeah
when they'd rented when I think of
gentrification though I think of
hipsters I don't think of like older
white guys I think it goes through that
rotation I think it goes five to ten
years hipsters and then you start to get
like oh it's really nice you know no
more crack cocaine and then it gets
nicer and nicer nicer hipsters never
find jobs and then neighborhood yes
what's happening is like the whole title
that's what was happening Oakland
because San Francisco's stupid expensive
Oakland was bad bad and now there's
parts of Oakland that are kind of
hipster and now they're starting to be
parts of Oakland you're like damn that's
an expensive ass house Oh ginger
vacation works they raise the price and
price all like like I think I think
that's why people don't like it because
they get priced out of their own
neighborhood oh my gosh brain control
baby so yeah so they get sexy with it
it's real babies money is sexy that's
right living in my own
best [ __ ] apartment for three years
and only having the ring not individual
taxes baby that's kinda like I don't
want any rent that's my goal
baby living in my car
baby [ __ ] common cereal with no milk
baby so so afterwards so they they rob
the house they take specifically forty
five thousand dollars in cash which
kills me because I know that they were
like okay fifty thousand dollars in cash
like if something happens like this will
help us this will like for the most part
in an emergency that will definitely
help you so we didn't take all of it
they also took eighty thousand dollars
worth of jewelry that kind of that's
what I'm saying they're all tall people
all people like to buy jewelry and
emulate stuff yeah I think I [ __ ] I'm
dead except for buzz everytime yeah
what's this image we're just in here
it's actually I think it's your
perspective is issue I think the
perspective is your issue that you think
getting old is bad yeah I think it's
good but the wait you're context though
we had context don't you present my
context was bad because I'm not listen
order my context was that I'm not your
mansplaining
yeah here I'm not accumulating enough
wealth as I'm getting to this awesome
you broke rich that's what I'm not rich
yet but the old parts kid did not
accumulating bad meme I'll I'm ready for
thirty
I feel like thirty is gonna be I love
being in my 30s I love being a favorite
I'm I'm living a good balance because we
still there yeah we have money now I
just don't have 125 calories
we all do dude I can feel myself getting
older in the face and it hurts like I
think I love you
yeah like ever even the bomb because I
said I love being within my 30s but I
just I don't wanna get any older in the
face I just want to keep getting older
without like but you're Asian I thought
a white person on my team I'm half white
cuz I think white people age the worst
huh are you you try to you try to say
aged poorly and I look white no I want
to join my team I thought you were white
like me because white people aged poorly
I said you look 27 I mean you do look
like 20 higher probably oh oh yeah there
we go they're living in a trash can
gotta put this on guys the police have
the two men left through a back door
with the family safe they took the whole
[ __ ] safe those things are expensive
a comb yeah and they flood in a blue
2008 grand Jeep Cherokee with a New York
license plate reading HTP three 9:06
because they're still on the runway
do I take you myself
if you do this I think they were mafia
people owe me
mom like you know it's too professional
Bob to us dude they had they've been
watching like they probably just knew
they were rich they probably didn't know
that the Saints out there you know
valuables go can you imagine though if
you like kind of scoped out a house
you're like alright I think they're rich
you guys say there's nothing there's
crickets in there if you don't have
anything no one could see you eating
that [ __ ]
[Music]